Narrator: In one hospital in Barcelona,
patients recovering from COVID-19
are relearning basic motor skills.
There's still so much we don't know
about the novel coronavirus.
Experts are confident that it
primarily attacks the lungs,
but more and more scientists
are finding other lingering effects,
even in the brain.
This is what physical therapy looks like
at Vall d'Hebron Hospital,
where doctors say
recovery can take months.
While many patients here
spend weeks in the ICU,
they developed blood clots in their lungs
that lead to strokes.
So medical professionals are monitoring
all possible complications,
from the moment patients
arrive at the hospital
to the time they are discharged.
62-year-old Daniel Catey, for example,
spent 21 days in the
ICU in an induced coma.
He had several strokes.
After receiving post-COVID
rehabilitation at the hospital,
now he's able to walk and talk again.
Many COVID patients
here also suffered from
inflammation in the brain.
Ramon Fite, a 67-year-old COVID survivor,
is currently in rehab.
After spending 15 days
sedated and intubated,
he was told there would be little hope.
Despite the difficulties in
dealing with the pandemic,
Dr. Sanchez says as patients get better,
medical staff get a boost.
In Spain, health officials
have flattened the curve,
allowing medical experts to focus on
the rehabilitation of its survivors.
Meanwhile, in the United States,
cases continue to climb and
ICU beds are filling up.